[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sports are our favorite soap opera and
right now the drama
it's on it's on fire right now and we
continue to dive into the nba playoffs
live in the group chat presented by
fanduel thank you for typing into the
bleacher report app my name is cabbie
richards
she still trusts the process while
combing through all the data that is
aaron dolan
and anywhere he goes he's alive he's a
vibe
that's greg ivory gregor claus has been
in full effect for the past couple of
weeks
are there any names left on your nice
list greg claus
cabbie in fact there are we got hoodies
as usual everybody we also got jerseys
i'm feeling generous i'm feeling
generous why not
uh this right here called candy dandy
ipad
and i'm gonna give away a jersey right
now why not give away a jersey
right now i am in the comments cabbie
and aaron in the comments
and i see uh
here we go i got tau
pakka 68 taopako 68 says
kd will put up 42 tonight shout out to
you talpaka those are good vibes
those are good guys for everybody that's
bending me over so uh
i'm going to sleep actually actually i'm
not sitting in a t-shirt i'm not sending
a hoodie you just want a jersey you just
want a 125
to pick out any jersey that you want
cabbie
let's get this show well done well done
all right well let's talk about the game
tonight in
their two home games in this series
brooklyn hit 36
three-pointers in milwaukee's last home
game
the bucks splash 16 three-pointers so
what we're saying is the three by two is
back ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
two three-pointers made in the first
three minutes of the game
last night the three by two hit in the
clippers versus jazz series
let's take a look and we want to thank
kawhi leonard and marcus morris
much appreciated gents there is the
terminator
kauai he hit three from downtown and
marcus morrison
had his best game in a clifford's
uniform going
five for six from three-point range so
let's look at tonight's game
shall we uh greg it looks like harden
is in for game five he's available so
there's a chance that he might hit a
couple of step backs but what does the
audience think about tonight's game
there are the odds for the three by two
minus 110.
what do we got how do they feel about it
let me ask him kathy let me ask him hey
audience uh
just reply yes how about that no no no
seriously seriously
here we go let me ask you will the three
by two hits harder than that
will the three by two hit tonight you
guys fill those comments up with
preferably yeses
and get creative uh but aaron i have to
talk to you i have to get your take i
have to get your rundown
do you think the 3x2 is hitting tonight
i mean fanduel has
has it at minus 110 like is it a lock
yes of course i mean how do you not put
the three by two cashing after those
stats cabbie mentioned as well and
that's
36 three pointers in the first two home
games of the series
shooters on both teams i'm taking this
three by two to cash and i'm excited
that it's back
the crowd is gonna be juiced tonight you
know
blake griffin or kevin durant might get
started for the nets and don't be
surprised if brooke lopez
oriannis for milwaukee splashes a three
and that three by two
hits before the nine-minute mark uh we
need these wins g-money are are we auto
locking the three by two
cabbie is the sky blue is
money green yes i mean it's not even a
question
it's not even a question whether we are
rocking this three
we're rocking with this three by two yes
we are hammering the three by two
uh but let me get into the comments let
me get into the comments
i see a i see a lot of creative gifts in
here cabbie i told them to be creative
and they
are i got name nameless
nameless shout out to you name what's
your welcome hoodie uh he has a funny
funny gift here saying yes
shout out to you namaste amazing
hold on here there it is
there it is i also got uh richie i got
richie 21 richie 21 with the smart uh
yes gif hey cabbie the the comments are
actually popping right now if you're not
in the comments you're losing
because this is how you get hoodies this
is how you get jerseys and uh
it's how you just you know get tapped in
on the show so shout out to everybody
that is rocking with us in the comments
i gave away two i gave away two i think
we can
i think we can we can move on i think we
can move on okay
hey salute to whoever that was with the
thor ragnarok
jif that was dope uh listen key injuries
have made this series so much harder to
cap for bookmakers
and fans james harden has been upgraded
to questionable
and he's going to participate in
warm-ups kyrie irving is out with a
badly twisted ankle
he was seen leaving milwaukee with an
air cast on his
on his foot so the question is can the
slim reaper
kevin durant carry his brooklyn nets to
victory
in game five how many points do you
think kd will score tonight against
against the milwaukee bucks greg what do
people have to do to take home a jersey
sir as
as we look at the the post on social
from earlier today
in order for you guys to take home a
jersey get in the comments and tell me
how many points
kd is putting up tonight at the end of
the game
we'll dm you one person who gets the
closest
and hook you up with the jersey aaron
kd is sitting at 33 and a half for
tonight
do you like that number do you like that
number you going over and under
so i'm actually going under on this
katie's only averaging 30 points per
game in the series he's not been able to
hit
over 33 and a half points in any of the
games during the series in game four
against the bucks he scored 28 points on
nine
of 25 shooting from the floor so i
expect to see some positive regression
from kd in terms
of his shooting performance but i'm
still taking under 33 and a half with
the potential that he could
be double teamed in this game also an
important note the line for kd's player
prop continues to move down and opened
at 35 and a half okay so
as g-money is about to give away jersey
aaron are you one of those sports fans
we know you're in philadelphia
that when the game is on you direct like
you thought on
one of your several uh philadelphia
sixers jerseys and which one did you
wear last night when
when embiid and korkmoz and ben simmons
took that l against atlanta
yeah see so i'm not like crazy
superstitious where i have to wear a
certain sixers
outfit basically in terms of wanting
them to win but last night i was laying
in bed and i was just getting more
heated and disappointed i was happy that
i didn't have any sixers gear on
i'm one of those fans but i definitely
get decked out in something philadelphia
sports every game
maybe you were the jigs because you
didn't wear their jersey like because i
didn't wear it this time
probably uh getting back to the the kd
conversation mike budenholzer is a great
coach he's one coach of the year before
i mean he does get knocked because in
the past he hasn't
been making that many in-game
adjustments
i think tonight the kd double team is
coming
you can't stop kevin durant you can only
hope to contain him
so send in bobby porter send pat
connaughton
send drew holiday on the weak side to
help professional justice tucker
who's built like thor ragnarok uh guard
uh kevin durant so um i'm gonna say
he's going under 33 and a half points
tonight and if james harden plays
15 to 20 minutes then maybe uh
harden will do some of the scoring that
uh kd would have done
without jane without the beard next to
him in the lineup so
under 33 and a half for me jimani do you
think that
katie will be irritated enough or thrown
off his game enough to score
under that 33 and a half that both aaron
and i think he will not hit tonight
cabbie i'm gonna have to go on the other
side of youtube
i actually think he's gonna be irritated
and that's gonna enhance his play
i saw katie actually talking to the
media earlier he had a quote saying that
in this game he's gonna have to do
everything if he's going in there
with that type of mindset kd might go
for 50 tonight
i mean nobody can guard him like no one
in i don't honestly i
really think no one 101 can guard kevin
durant
in the nba i mean you named you named
drew holiday
pat connington bobby portis no no kevin
no no help not the primary defenders
help defenders no cabbie no
i mean even if they come bring the help
i i see
katie being a playmaker we know he can
do this we saw this in golden state i
mean we've seen it
at times with this this uh brooklyn team
katie's gonna be okay he's gonna be okay
he's gonna have a really good game but i
think he's gonna score
the basketball i do think he's going to
score the basketball let me get into
these comments though cubby
let me get into these comments because i
got king of sports he's he's agreeing
with me king of sports says
40 piece mark my word kd will ball
tonight
shout out to you kingdom sports 21 you
are walking away with a hoodie
uh i got i got money man 13 says
over kd is taking over and it's in
brooklyn meaning kd is going to show up
in brooklyn tonight cabbie
so shout out to my guy money man because
i'm a man of my money too
uh you're walking away with the honey uh
here we go i got i got king smooth
king's move says nah and hardin will
lead a game into the first quarter
bucks in six so he says katie's going
under he's rocking with you aaron
and you cabbie kingsmove 23 uh
underscore six shout out to you you're
walking away with a hoodie
um everybody what i need you guys to do
is get into the comments
give me a number give me a number that
you think kevin durant is going to end
the game with
whoever gets the closest whoever gets
the closest
gonna give you a jersey i am gonna give
you a jersey uh
we're also gonna give away two more
jerseys in this show we're gonna give
away two more cabbie we're giving away
two more aaron
the the gifts are still flowing
dope are we are we doing like wheel of
fortune rules like closest without going
over
cabbie that's a great question that is a
great question
hopefully i mean you know we have a lot
of people in the comments somebody get
it
right on the dot but yeah okay
but yeah hopefully somebody gets it
right on the dot
uh but we'll see man we'll see we might
have to go you know
i have to talk to the powers that may be
and see
and see to figure it out
the jersey gatekeepers right i like this
comment from zappo45 who wrote
22 points at one point in the game one
of his sneakers will fly off his foot
i love it uh listen uh
yeah congratulations apple 25's getting
a hoodie for that
while injury talk has dominated the
betting sphere and
sports talk radio the greek god yana
santa takuma who's quietly averaging
30 points 12 rebounds and three assists
in this series nobody's talking about
the greek god
and he's a guy one of the most fun props
player props to bet on is points
plus rebounds plus assists g money which
fan of brooklyn or
milwaukee or maybe even philly like
aaron um
needs a journey a jersey to enjoy the
rest of the series
and potentially an appearance in the nba
finals
let me find out kevin let me talk to him
get in the comments guys and tell me how
many points
rebounds and assists giannis is putting
up tonight
i'm going to give away a hoodie and a
jersey
for this one aaron are you on the over
or under here
so i'm on the under here like cabbie
mentioned in this series greek freak
averaging 30 points 12 boards three
assists so off the bat
51 and a half seems way too high for me
especially given that he has not hit
over that number in any of the games
played in this series now it's going to
be a huge game for giannis inside the
barclays center but i hate
taking unders as well but i have to go
under for this prop
there's uh 51 and a half is is a high
number for giannis but he is
he can i mean it's attainable for him
he's an elite scorer an elite rebounder
a pretty solid passer
strategically i think the reason he
doesn't
get to 51 and a half points rebounds and
assists tonight
is free throws giannis is dreadful
in the playoffs if i'm steve nash then
i'm hacking the god in the fourth
quarter
and putting him on the charity stripe
because he's shooting under
40 from three free throws so
uh that's why i think he's going under
the 51 and a half
aaron when you watch ben simmons in
philadelphia
get to the free throw line are you i
created punch your
like you cringe i cringe i cringed so
hard and they kept doing it on purpose
which was even worse and every time you
go to the line i couldn't even watch it
was terrible
they should have live lines whenever he
goes to the line
over under too oh that's not a bad idea
that's not a bad we and greg and i
watched uh watched him last night
and i'm not sure that he hit one free
free throw against the hawks he gave
four
uh g-money um giannis giannis is in
brooklyn tonight there's likely going to
be a star-studded audience
we know that the queen bee has has
attended hove
has attended travis scott has been there
for some of these brooklyn
nets games do you think that the greek
god is going to go off tonight
oh gabby that's an interesting question
that is an interesting question because
the lights are going to be bright in
brooklyn
like you said i mean we're going to have
celebrities in the stands
it's going to be a big game all eyes are
going to be on this game tonight it's
2-2
you know the winner is going to take uh
take a lead in this series
i do see giannis i do see him having a
good game tonight i do see him having a
good game tonight ducey and possibly
putting on the show
but is he gonna put on an absolute show
i don't know
i don't know if he's gonna put on this
show to go over 51 and a half
on this combined points rebounds and
assists that is a lot of points
i mean that's a lot that's a lot that is
a lot
uh it's a it's a lot of points it's a
lot of rebounds and it's a lot of
assist but uh so i'm gonna go under here
i'm gonna go under
kathy you made a great point about the
free throws giannis i mean he goes to
the free throw line and he misses more
than he makes
so i mean that could be a key point in
in not winning this bet or betting if i
was to bet the over and losing so
i'm gonna just rock with the under here
stick with the under hey uh hold on
that's enough
wait aaron do you want to change yours
cause i don't know if the three of us
have ever been in agreement
on one of these the player props like i
don't know what's going on
on him after the last time they were
playing in barclays there they got blown
out
that's a good point they like they were
down by 49 points at one point in games
that was bad right
yeah it just means that we're all in
agreement but all right we're just gonna
have to let him ride you money
this is rare yeah this is rare let's
just you know let's just keep the vibes
maybe the vibes are maybe we got some
good vibes going right here
we're all on the same side for once so
uh yeah let's just let it ride but i'm
in the comments gabby i'm in the
comments i need to give away
i need to give away a hoodie and i need
to give away a jersey
um i'm in the comments cabbie aaron
and i see boston versus
everyone they say 42 points 14
boards six assists heard it here first
i'm
taking the over with the greek god
hey shout out to you boston shout out
you're walking away with a hoodie oh go
white sox is in the comments cabbie
go white sox is in the comments aaron uh
he's going with the
under and he has the giannis hitting the
wall you guys
right there you see the whoa you go you
know what i'm doing
how you do it show us how to do it here
no i'm not gonna embarrass myself here
i'm giving away a jersey here right now
give away a jersey
here we go in the comments in the
comments
i see richie 21 richie 21 got 32
14 and six 32 14
that's 52 that means he's going with the
over shout out to you richie
uh even though you're fading me guess
what i'm i'm i'm being generous you're
gonna walk away
with the jersey of your choice
very dope okay we're three hours we're
under three hours before tip off
so we asked you on twitter who's going
to win this series
milwaukee or boston let's see the
twitter poll
there's plus money there with the
brooklyn nets at plus 154
america is voting
51 with brooklyn i guess they like that
plus
money uh greg brooklyn is a home dog
tonight
and an underdog in this series as we see
plus 154
how are you and your winners only army
feeling about the nets
in game five and this series cabbie i'm
loving the plus money
actually if you've hey if you guys had a
future ticket on the nets
i mean you might as well spring with
some more because i'm loving this and
that's plus money right now
i'm loving it but you guys get in the
comments tell me who you
think is winning this series i'm giving
away a jersey to the hottest take why
not
aaron talk to me i know you see that
plus money
plus 120 is looking mighty tempting who
do you think has won in this area
milwaukee
or brookwood i have to take brooklyn
with the plus money now i know it hasn't
been announced just yet the severity of
kyrie irving's
ankle injury but the nets are accustomed
to playing without that trio on the
floor i mean
kd harding and kyrie only played eight
games together during the regular
season another alarming stat i read last
night the nets have won
four of the five games with kevin durant
playing even without
james harden or kyrie on the floor so
i'm gonna go with the nets to win the
series i think the last game with kd not
being prepared to lose kyrie
kind of threw him off just a tad so i
think now that we know that
you know james harden could potentially
be back in he might have a different
mindset
i think the nets win the series but i
think they do it in game seven in the
barclays center
hot take okay i love it i love it every
remaining team in the playoffs has a
significant
injury to their starting lineup except
for phoenix
we saw that brawn couldn't get out of
the first round without anthony davis
philadelphia is without danny green
atlanta's without deandre hunter
uh there's no serge ibaka in l.a mike
conley
is suffering from a hamstring injury
just like james harden
add kyrie badly twisting his ankle and i
think
in this specific case with brooklyn and
milwaukee
the injuries are too significant to
overcome
there's no pressure on kevin durant
without a superstar teammates but
there's a ton of upside
however i think the healthy i'm gonna go
with the healthier team
in this this case i'm siding with the
with the books
give me the milwaukee bucks to win in
six or seven
obviously they can only win in six or
seven but give me the milwaukee bucks
to advance the eastern conference finals
and potentially play
aaron's 76ers uh g-money have you
changed your mind about
the brooklyn nets considering you hold a
futures ticket
on that squad without their superstars
in the lineups or
not fully healthy superstars in the
lives
cabbie i've not changed my mind not
changed my mind at all
i haven't changed my mind at all sir uh
i see them winning this series and this
is like i keep on saying it but this
plus money
on the brooklyn nets to win the series
you guys go go get on this
now because uh i like it i like it a lot
um i do see them winning this series
they're getting james harden back
today hopefully i mean you know
hopefully everything goes goes well
uh you know he's a big asset for this
team him with kd i i
cabbie i personally think him and kd can
get it done not
what i mean get it done win the whole
thing by themselves so if they get
james back and then they get kyrie back
and then the three
the three the big threes uh come on cavi
come on man
come on so i like this a lot i like this
a lot let me give away some hoodies
though let me give away some hoodies
and also giving away a jersey um
here we go i need i got katie the great
says
i need to rep the next jersey after they
win the series
so he's locking in and then he also says
nets don't need kyrie to beat the bucks
next in seven shout out to you katie's a
great you're walking away with a hoodie
stop
it stop gabby stop it
what did he say wrong
what did he say i guess we'll see i
guess we'll see because kyrie
will probably i don't know how quickly
he recovers maybe he's an x-men
uh or some kind of superhero but that
when he rolled his ankle on giannis's
foot bro like all his body weight came
on his
ankle come on nets winning without kyrie
against the bucks stop
i mean we'll see cabbie i mean i i i get
i do like i just said it i i just said
it if if
james harden comes back i can see james
and katie winning it all i i can see it
i can definitely see it but kevin let me
give him somebody
aaron 76ers they got simmons and
thibault will put
i was going to say put the clamps they
will apprise from some pressure
not full clamps but some pressure on
hardin and and kd
those two are those two dudes are elite
anyway sorry please
please
what i feel like it's almost like the
whole situation with a.d when we were
talking about this a couple weeks ago
just when he was gonna come in and see
how he plays and now we kind of are in
the same situation with hardin
so we're banking on him to be okay but i
don't know if we can really do that just
yet but i still
feel like we're i mean that's a plus
money i feel like you have to take that
over the
millennium hold on that's a great point
aaron because
because like we saw in with anthony
davis
did he come back too fast he was not a
hundred percent
and then ultimately foamies out again
james hart like he was out for a month
with the hamstring injury and all of a
sudden he's gonna be back in like i
don't know a week
ten days to then play at 100
effort and intensity in the playoff yeah
[Music]
i like your sixers aaron over the nets
and i definitely like the milwaukee
bucks over the nets
it's a good point
your next ticket you both you both have
good points uh i still think the next
get it done even with the
85 percent james harden uh
yeah i need to give away some of these
hoodies and i also got to give away a
jersey
here we go i got d g h e r says uh
milwaukee and seven the greek freak
ain't losing shout out to you dg her
although you're fading me i'm still
giving you a hoodie
uh i'll give away one more hoodie cabbie
uh memito memito16 says the nets are
undefeated at home
against the bucks uh i believe that is
correct
i mean i believe i believe that is this
correct shout out to you mimito
16 you're walking away with hoodie
cabbie aaron i'm giving away
uh i'm giving away a jersey now let me
just give away this jersey
here we go i got julio hernandez says
uh greg the brooklyn nets are going to
win the series in seven games
until giannis can put
so sorry he wrote a paragraph until
giannis
can hit perimeter shots and free throws
on a consistent basis
he will cost the bucks in the playoffs
katie is the best player in the series
nets in seven hot tape julio hernandez
shout out to you you are walking away
with the jersey for your hot take
uh i mean we'll see we'll see how the
series plays out
cabbie that is a hot take uh well done
listen uh john hollinger said that
availability is
ability and in this year's playoffs it
feels like
the healthiest team has the best chance
of winning the nba championship the
sports books
are leaning in that direction as well
except for the brooklyn nets
again james harden's health is
questionable kyrah irving's health is
questionable
but there's no question that the
brooklyn nets are still the betting
favorites
to win this year's nba championship
let's take a look at the latest odds
brooklyn is right there with plus 300
the milwaukee bucks at plus 390. phoenix
is at plus 390.
utah is at plus 390 and then the
la clippers at plus 550
uh let's
sorry they're having trouble with uh mr
sun came out here um
so g money is the audience still on
the brooklyn nets uh
the audience let me ask them cabbie get
in the comments and tell me who you guys
think is winning it all can the nets do
it with harden
and kd i think so aaron
what do you think who are you rocking
with
craig i feel like we keep rocking with
the nets so as you mentioned
cabbie just the healthiest team is
probably going to win the nba finals i
understand that there's wear and tear on
basically every team remaining as a fan
of course want the 76ers to win it all
but i'm really worried about embiid's
health
especially after last night's loss that
that whole series being two and two that
should not be the case right now so the
next twin at all plus 300
right now is my play just given that i
think if they win this game tonight or
even the next game those
odds are going to come down so if you
really like those odds now i would get
them i think the suns come out of the
west i'm rooting for them
but i don't think they'll be able to
actually win it all this year so i'm
going to go with the next
aaron at this point with embiid's torn
meniscus do you think that you can jump
higher than him
no way no way i got that
all five don't jumping higher than
embiid no way well listen he doesn't
have that much
lift i mean g buddy and i were at the
game and it was it was pretty
i kind of cringe when i watch him play a
little bit right now too i'm so worried
he's going to be injured on every play
he is he is laboring and listen i have
of
philadelphia 76ers and an la clippers
futures ticket
uh and i try not to be a prisoner of the
moment what i saw last night with embiid
going all for 12
in the second half i was like uh and
then what i saw in
in la on the other side both paul
george and kawhi leonard having
back-to-back 30-point games
is historic but the road to the nba
finals
goes to this goes through salt lake city
and the utah jazz are amazing at home
and they have the number one seed
they've earned it and that
home court advantage will be um
will be significant donovan mitchell
we're not even talking about him
but he's been electric he's averaging 37
points
per game in this series against the
clippers uh
and uh and here but here's the thing
this one gives me
it gives me a little bit of hope for my
la clippers futures ticket if
mike conley doesn't play in the next
three games
i think that la can steal one in salt
lake city
and then win at the staples center they
can take care of the phoenix suns
who've been resting for it might end up
being like eight or nine days
that rest can turn into rust and maybe
maybe they could steal a game in phoenix
so i like i've got uh a flyer something
a flash game a six-inch ticket
la clippers that's my pick to win the
nba championship and i love the plus 550
get these odds while you can uh g money
do you believe that your guy kevin
durant can carry
the brooklyn nets without his superstar
teammates at full
health oh cabbie
that is a really really good question
and i'll be honest
as good as i think kd is
by himself i don't think so
i don't think so gabby so he needs he
needs
james or kyrie to be on on the team in
order for
them to win this championship but uh
i'm rocking with the nets i'm rocking
with the nets i've been rocking with
them
since the beginning since the beginning
of the season i'm not going to change my
bet now
uh get him at plus 300 like aaron said
get him right now
because this is going to change after
tonight's game after the w
i'm predicting it now you guys know
where my bet is on the game
after the w this is gonna change uh
let me give away some hoodies let me
give away some hoodies cabbie kelly
i mean not kelly aaron's so sorry here
we go in the comments in the comments
sons will win it all
good night shout out to dg h e r d g h e
r
sons will win it all shout out to you
you're walking away with the hoodie i
think you already have one but
why not we'll send you another one here
we go i got motivated
motivated uh chris paul you got chris
paul in the suns
in the comments uh there it is chris
paul
with the gift shout out to you motivated
you're walking over the tabby i got one
more
one more in me one more uh
wade zero eight twenty one you're going
to like this aaron
he said let's go philly taking it all
this year
shout out to you wade zero eight those
are good vibes
uh there it is there it is the people
have spoken
gabby they spoke thank you thank you so
much for tapping into the group chat
presented by fanduel remember what you
learned today
the audience and greg and bruh
and and aaron are on the brooklyn nets
to win this series and win the nba
championship the 3x2
is back so let's get it tonight and
we'll be back next week
for uh to give away more hoodies more
jerseys and more locks alongside aaron
dolan
and greg ivory my name is gabby richards
we are leaving the group chat please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you